from Christian dear Knowles can you
prove the Gospels really are authentic
and why don't the why the Jews don't see
it that way well I don't I don't know
that the Jews writ large question the
historicity of the Gospels certainly
they don't believe in the divinity of
Christ by definition I suppose but the
scholarly consensus is clear the
scholarly consensus right now is that
the Gospel according to mark was written
within 40 years of Jesus's death
Matthew within 40 to 70 years Luke
within 30 to 60 years John within 50 to
65 years that's on the outside end so
think about it this way would you trust
a biography today that was written about
Andy Kaufman Andy Kaufman was about 35
years old when he died he died about 33
years ago would you trust that or would
you say no that's absolutely ridiculous
how could they know about Andy Kaufman
oh there are people alive who knew him
and we have movies and we have books
about him historians all certainly also
agree that about Jesus's baptism by John
the Baptist and his death by Pontius
Pilate they all agree that those
occurred they might disagree about some
of the miracles Flavius Josephus the
Roman historian writes about Christ and
his followers Tacitus the Talmud writes
about Christ it I think it's very
fashionable now to question the
historicity of Christ or to question the
Gospel accounts we know more about him
than we know about virtually anyone else
of that era
we know who we and we can rely on more
than that so when you engage with the
text on that level but you should just
read it you should read these accounts
and encounter this person and then
you'll have to grapple with Christ
himself
you'll have to grapple with the person
of Christ and see us Lewis writes about
this when you meet him you have three
options he's either a liar he's either
just deceiving people going around
deceiving everybody or he's a lunatic
and he's seen he's just a total crazy
person or he's the Lord or he's the
person he says he is and I'll tell you
when you read those books he sure
doesn't come off as a liar he has no
incentive to be a liar and he doesn't
get great rewards for his lies that's
certainly true infinite torture on a
cross and he doesn't seem a lunatic he
does not sound like a lunatic
when you read him and you read
his piercing words and his and his
piercing actions so it's hard not to
conclude the latter but your mileage
might vary you should read it yourself